[оплески]
[музика]
Слава Україні Слава Україні
хасиди готуються зустрічати юдейський
Новий рік в Умані
співаємо танцюємо читаємо молитви це Вау
приїхати сюди
[музика]
тут похований цадик тобто праведник
хасидів рабі нахман
нахмана Ми не можемо почати Новий рік
він наш заступник на небі цього вечора
починається роль гашана три книги Біблії
відкриваються на небі
ми житимемо чи помремо будемо бідними Чи
багатими щасливими чи сумними там це
написано
попри заклики української та
ізраїльської влади утриматися від
поїздок в Україну на черкащину прибули
понад 35 тисяч хасидів востаннє стільки
паломників тут було до пандемії
коронавірусу вам страшно було приїхати
сюди
ні Мені було страшно не приїхати сюди
або чуєте сигнал повітряної тривоги
найперша молитимемося Богу щоб він нас
захистив Ми віримо в Бога це наша Надія
лише бог він може все А як щодо
протиповітряної оборони ППО теж Бог хто
контролює світ хто контролює ППО вас
мене лише Бог
здебільшого повітряну тривогу хасиди
ігнорують міська Влада визнає що
достатньої кількості укриттів в Умані
немає у кварталі паломників одне зі
сховищ має ось такий вигляд
[музика]
це підвал поруч із головною святинею
могилою рабі нахмана тут паломники
моляться іноді під музику
[музика]
[оплески]
надвечір коли заходить сонце і незабаром
з'їде перша зірка починається шабат і
незабаром розпочнеться власне
святкування рольшана Нового року
паломники вже виходять на вулиці вже
починають співати танцювати і молитися
вони вдягають свій найкращий одяг білого
кольору тому що він символізує чистоту
адже Новий рік потрібно зустрічати
чистим
[оплески]
щоб Новий Рік був справді чистим
готуються і комунальники
[музика]
це там зібрала вивезла
щоб на завтра було легше і ввечері
вивезуть
[музика]
комендантська година святкування у
гасицькому кварталі не зупиняє упри
зусилля поліції
у кварталі паломництва діє низка
обмежень Тут заборонений продаж алкоголю
і піротехніки посилено чергує поліція і
українська і ізраїльська поліція
напередодні проводила роз'яснювальну
роботу і зустрічі із
равинами які і доносили інформацію до
паломники про те що в разі коли звучить
повітряна тривога то їм Звичайно що
потрібно прямувати до укриття окрім того
наголошувались на дотриманні правил
комендантської години яка у нас
розпочинається з 001 і триває до
четвертої години ранку і ще доносилась
інформація за окремими тими обмеженнями
і заборонами які є в місті Умані та
хасиди живуть за своїми правилами
наприклад багатьох не турбує що
доводиться жити разом з десятьма людьми
в одній квартирі
як дорого коштує винайняти кімнату
у шекелях не знаю скільки у гривнях
2400 шекелів за кімнату на кілька днів
Скільки людей у кімнаті п'ятеро нетісно
не так і погано У нас хороша кімната
багато кімнат ще менші люди приїздять з
усього світу живуть у маленьких кімнатах
і платять багато грошей лише аби
провести час біля могили святої людини
місце щоб переночувати коштує від 200
доларів якщо не чуєш у кращому місці в
готелі
1200 доларів
за ніч ні за весь тиждень що далі від
центру хасидського кварталу то дешевше
ри ше
стеро Ізраїлі
Ну в мене наприклад получилося по 120 а
вообще-то більше буває будуть бо я
наперед домовилась не знала
за весь період А ось найдешевший варіант
для великої родини головне поруч із
могилою ради нахмана
автомобільним транспортом тобто вони на
жаль не можуть проживати дуже далека від
зони паломництва вони обирають проживати
наскільки це можливо близько до могили
саме тому можливо це також є причиною
Чому вони обирають оселитися може не
дуже гарних умовах однак поруч з могилею
більшість готелів у гасицькому кварталі
побудовані незаконно отримавши дозвіл на
триповерхову споруду забудовники зводять
по 9 поверхів офіційних готелі тут 3-4
решта не платять туристичний збір саме
тому як пояснюють у міськраді в Умані
запровадили податок з кожного паломника
цього року він складає 335 гривень
людини на добу сплачувати його готові не
всі
євреї люблять гроші але тут ми бачимо що
всі люблять гроші для мене це дивно бо
якщо ти тонеш ти мав би цілувати руку
яку тобі простягують для допомоги
ізраїльтяни приїжджають в Україну варто
бути більш густиними
це здирництво Кажи як є це здирництво а
Ви заплатили ці гроші
я не можу сказати бо тут поліція поруч
але ні не заплатив але думаю більшість
заплатили
в 22-му році коли започаткували такий
туристичний збір місто отримуло порядка
10 мільйонів і хотів би зазначити що в
цьому році ми однозначно запровадили
запровадили ще один такий інноваційний
туристичний збір - це онлайн сплата
туристичного збору орієнтовна сума на
сьогоднішній день Що мені відомо це
порядка 17-18 млн бюджет за ці кошти в
цьому році ми однозначно плануємо
витратити їх на нашій лікарні частково а
іншу частину ми витратимо на збройні
сили України на допомогу нашим
військовим період паломництва на могилу
садика рабінахмана цей заробіток для
деяких уманчан Сантехнік Олег протягом
місяця може заробити 20 тисяч гривень
тоді як його звична ставка 12 тисяч
розташовану відносяться погано до всього
викидають багато у власних салфеток
забувається каналізація ну Ізраїлі може
інша якась
Коли будують ці думати вони повинні
розщітувати в два-три рази збільшувати
мощності труби для того щоб дуже великий
наплив людей з-за того це Всі проблеми
Ірина 8-й рік на рожгашана протягом
минулих років вона працювала на
хасидській кухні на сьогоднішній день
була ціна 50 грн час Ну якби ми хочемо
для роботи і хоч не йде не работає і ну
Решета вони там піднімають Ну то есть
если вони платили Я тобі до цього 50 грн
максимально ти можеш вибити 70 гривень
її це буде ну це буде просто твій
потолок нині Ірина торгує в крамниці у
кварталі хасидів адже тут потрібно була
продавчиня Утім наступного року жінка
готова повернутися на хасидську кухню
попри специфічні умови роботи почистити
нарізати ну принести помогти на то есть
українці не можуть готувати тому що це
считай ну если хлопці то да вони їх
допускають якби готовки їжі а жінок ні
от ви ж так працювали як вам взагалі там
працювалися як ставилися до вас Ну
по-перше вони сильно Ну вони халять я не
із тих людей що я буду мовчати я зразу
пояснюю що я можу і двінуть Ну то есть
как бы меня абсолютно всё равно українок
вони бояться якщо ти показуєш що ні ти
мені сюда Не сядеш я тебе швиденько
скину ну тобто вони до тебе тоді
ставляться З повагою поки їхні жінки
вдома хасиди святкують деякі моляться за
Україну на святі не відчуваються напруги
Віталій камузін представник об'єднаної
єврейської общини відзначає українці
Навчаються жити з паломниками мирно
в цьому році взагалі рівень організації
паломництва дуже високий а відносно
минулих років і в цьому році був лише
один випадок до конденсімітизму в
соціальних мережах але і на той поліція
дуже сильно зреагувала оперативно а
наприклад у 20-му році пам'ятаю що тут
були і побої і ножові і так далі в цьому
році все дуже спокійно
Я знаю Деякі люди виглядають дивно
незвично їх бачити ми бачимо людей які
виглядають по-іншому іноді це нас лякає
але під цими костюмами звичайні люди
іноді Божевільні особливо люди які
приїжджають в Умань треба бути трошки
божевільним щоб приїхати в Україну в
такий час але деякі Божевільні люди
дійсно хороші
[музика]